Hi, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich bin Markus, ich moderiere hier normalerweise das Chaosradio, aber ich werde gleich wieder verschwinden. Denn ja, ihr hört das Chaosradio feed, aber was jetzt gleich kommt, ist genau genommen kein Chaosradio, sondern ein neues spannendes Projekt, das wir euch ans Herz legen wollen. In dicke Bretter soll nämlich erklärt werden, wie Gesetze und politische Initiativen zu digitalen Themen entstehen und wie die Institutionen arbeiten, in denen Regeln, Urteile oder auch Regulierungen gemacht werden. Man könnte es auch anders formulieren. Man könnte sagen, während das Chaosradio oft genug fragt, wer hat eigentlich jetzt schon wieder genau was angezündet und wie löschen wir das, geht es in dicke Bretter eher darum herauszufinden, wer eigentlich die ganze Zeit Holz produziert und das fein säuberlich zu Scheiterhaufen aufstapelt. All das erwartet euch künftig ungefähr alle zwei Monate. Dicke Bretter ist ein Podcast von und mit Elisa Lindinger, Elina Eickstädt und Constanze Kurz, der in Kooperation mit Netzpolitik Org entsteht und von Louis produziert wurde. Aber genug von mir, ich verschwinde wie versprochen jetzt wieder und wünsche euch viel Spaß mit Dicke Bretter.
Willkommen, liebe Hörer und Hörerinnen, zu unserem Podcast Dicke Bretter. Wir werden gleich ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, was wir in Dicke Bretter machen wollen. Aber wir wollen uns am Anfang ein bisschen vorstellen. Und beginnen wird Elisa, die etwas ganz kurzes über sich sagen wird.
Hi, ich bin Elisa und ich bin eigentlich Archäologin, aber arbeite seit ein paar Jahren, wenn nicht sogar schon seit über einem Jahrzehnt auch im netzpolitischen Bereich.
Und die zweite in der Runde ist Elina, die auch noch mal einen Satz über sich sagen wird.
Hi, ich bin Elina oder auch Khaleesi, wie die ein oder andere mich kennen wird. Ich bin Informatikerin und treibe seit ja so knapp ein Jahr sehr aktiv mein Unwesen im CCC.
Ja, und die Runde komplett macht Constanze, das bin ich. Mein Name ist Constanze Kurz und ich bin Informatiker und Hacker. Ich arbeite in der Redaktion von netzpolitik.org und bin ehrenamtliche Sprecherin des Chaos Computer Clubs. Und wir drei, sozusagen die beste Runde, wo es gibt in Tech Policy, wird sich genau mit diesem Thema beschäftigen. Wir wollen über Policies reden, nicht gerade das sexiestes Thema vielleicht, wie man sich vorstellen kann, aber nicht für uns, weil wir uns gesagt haben, es gibt eine ganze Menge dicke Bretter zu bohren. Und zwar darin, wie eigentlich, wie sich eine Meinung und später auch eine Gesetzgebung bildet und wie die Institutionen aussehen, in denen die Gesetze gemacht werden, aber auch die Policies. Und dafür haben wir eine relativ lange Liste erstellt und dann haben wir gedacht, hey, machen wir doch einen Podcast drauf. Soweit, weil wir uns selber darin einbringen, in Gesetzgebungsprozesse, aber auch in Policy, Rahmengremien und weil wir auch schon einige Jahre als politische Beobachter dabei sind und uns damit beschäftigen und weil uns auch die Technologie und Netzpolitik am Herzen liegt. Wir werden jetzt zur Vorstellung von unserer Runde nicht gleich alle Themen nennen, die wir besprechen wollen, aber auf jeden Fall fangen wir oben an bei den Vereinten Nationen und bei internationalen Organisationen und wollen runtergehen sozusagen zur Brüsseler Ebene, zur Berliner Ebene, in den Bundestag und auch manchmal in die Landtagsebene. Aber wir wollen uns auch ein bisschen mit den Litigation Policy Rahmenbedingungen beschäftigen, also Leute, die zum Beispiel strategische Prozessführung oder generell Höchstgerichte anrufen, um damit politische Vorhaben durchzusetzen, also die ganze Reihe an Policy-Ebenen, die wir so haben. Das ist unser Plan und wir hoffen, dass wir da interessante, spannende Themen zusammengeholt haben. Und die erste, die wir angehen wollen, ist eine Organisation, die jeder kennt. Und dabei werden wir uns mal so ein bisschen auf die Stadt beziehen, in der sie stattfindet. Und wer von euch will mal beginnen zu sagen, was verbindet ihr mit dieser Stadt und welche riesengroße Organisationen und warum habt ihr da besucht?
Ja, wir waren in der Stadt, deren Skyline wahrscheinlich eine der berühmtesten der Welt ist. Eine, die angeblich mehr Screentime hat, als die berühmtesten Hollywood-Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler, nämlich New York und da ist das Hauptquartier der Vereinten Nationen. Die verschiedenen Institutionen der UN, die sind über unterschiedliche Länder und Städte verteilt, aber der Hauptsitz ist eben in New York. Spannenderweise, weil John D. Rockefeller Junior da ein großes Gelände am East River gespendet hat und das hat dann die UN dazu bewegt, sich in New York niederzulassen.
Und ihr wart da auch drin, also genau in diesem, was sicherlich alle noch vom Fernsehen oder aus dem Internet kennen, in diesem riesigen Gebäude habt ihr mit verhandelt, korrekt?
Also ob wir da mit verhandelt haben, das werden wir vielleicht im weiteren Verlauf noch weiter ausführen, aber wir waren auf jeden Fall zwei Wochen da und konnten dort auch ein- und ausgehen, wie wir lustig waren, haben wir auch gemacht.
Genau, die UN, die hat verschiedene Einrichtungen, die da tagen und wir waren konkret bei der CSW, bei der Commission on the Status of Women. Das ist ein jährliches Gremium, das unter dem ECOSOC, also dem Council für Wirtschaft und Soziales, tagt. Das findet seit, das muss ich selber überlegen, seit 1946 glaube ich jährlich statt. Und da geht es, wie der Name schon sagt, das Status of Women vor allem um Frauenrechte, um Gleichstellungsfragen. Und dieses Jahr gab es aber ein Schwerpunktthema, das sich um Digitales und Technologie drehte. Das war auch tatsächlich das allererste Mal, dass dieses Thema da auf der Agenda stand. Und da konnten wir uns das nicht entgehen lassen und sind nach New York gereist.
Da gehe ich mal gleich mit bei Beispiele. Wo ist der vielleicht nicht offensichtliche Zusammenhang zwischen Frauenthemen und Technik? Wo waren da so die Schwerpunkte, dass man gleich mal eine Idee kriegt?
Ja, also ich glaube, da, also wo der Schwerpunkt dann tatsächlich war, ist noch mal ein anderes Thema. Aber grundsätzlich der vorgegebene Schwerpunkt, da ging es primär um Ausbildung natürlich, aber auch irgendwie das Thema Gendergerechtigkeit und Technologie und Reproduzieren von bestimmten Narrativen durch Technologie. Genau, und natürlich auch das Thema Frauen und Zugang zu Technologie. Also das sind so der Grundumschlag, mit dem wir es da theoretisch zu tun hätten, haben können. Genau.
Das Spannende ist aber, dass da natürlich sich 193 Länder oder Vertreterinnen und Vertreter treffen und natürlich sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Vorbedingungen mitbringen. Also was für uns ein Thema ist, das wir dort besprechen wollen würden, das ist von anderes Land vielleicht gerade völlig irrelevant, entweder weil sie es schon gelöst haben oder weil die beim Breitbandausbau ähnlich schlecht dastehen wie wir in Deutschland. Also da sind die Ausforderungen tatsächlich ganz unterschiedlich. Und ja, das muss erstmal verhandelt werden. Worüber sprechen wir eigentlich? Also auch die Themenwahl selbst ist schon ein Politikum.
Aber nun hast du gerade so einfließen lassen, da kommen die Länder zusammen. Für welches Land sollten wir vielleicht mal erwähnen? Wart ihr denn da? Das wird jetzt niemand großartig überraschen.
Ja, genau, ich war Teil der deutschen Regierungsdelegation. Das wird organisiert vom BMFSFJ, also dem Familienministerium.
In der unteren Klasse darunter, es gibt nämlich eine Zweiklassengesellschaft bei diesen Events. Es gibt die Mitglieder der offiziellen Delegation der Länder. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch zivilgesellschaftliche Delegationen, die auch Akkreditierung haben. Und ich war Teil der Delegation des Deutschen Frauenrats.
Also das ist quasi ein Beobachtungsstatus, kann man so sagen?
Ja, kann man, kann man glaube ich so sagen. Wobei Teil der deutschen Delegation sein war ja auch ein bisschen ein Beobachtungsposten ein Stück weit. Da kommt es wahrscheinlich auch glaube ich ganz darauf an, wie sehr die Länder auch die Delegationsmitglieder fördern und befragen zu den unterschiedlichen Themen.
Und da kommen wir aber schon zum spannenden Punkt, finde ich. Nämlich, wie wird da eigentlich verhandelt bei der UN? Wir kennen vielleicht alle diese Bundestagsdebatten oder Anhörungen, die ja auch gelivestreamt werden. Und bei der UN hatte ich das Gefühl, dass das dort grundlegend anders passiert. Also da gibt es vorher schon eine Art Zero Draft, also einen allerersten Entwurf für sogenannte Agreed Conclusions, also der Minimalkonsens der Teilnehmenden, der Regierungsvertreterinnen dort. Und die werden dann bloß noch geschärft, gekürzt, leicht verändert. Aber da geht es jetzt nicht mehr so sehr darum, dass da im Plenum die ganz harten Debatten geführt werden oder Brandreden geschwungen werden. Also das hat mich mir tatsächlich vorher ein bisschen anders vorgestellt.
Ja, kann man so sagen, also wir sind da glaube ich auch so ein bisschen mit der Vorstellung hingefahren. Okay, wir fahren da jetzt hin als Vertreterin der Zivilgesellschaft in der einen oder der anderen Form. Und dann bekommen wir eigentlich einen Einblick da rein, was da jetzt eigentlich verhandelt wird und was da eigentlich hin und her geschoben wird. Und vielleicht haben wir auch die Chance, an den wichtigen Stellen anzumerken, was uns jetzt gerade daran stört, gegebenenfalls irgendwie angehört zu werden in irgendeiner Form. Und das war halt nicht der Fall. Also es ist dann doch nochmal noch mehr Kontrastprogramm. Also ich mache ja viel auf EU-Ebene zu dem, was da auf EU-Ebene zum Beispiel läuft, wenn man als zivilgesellschaftliche Vertreterin mit einer bestimmten Expertise zu irgendwas eingeladen wird. Also es ist so ein bisschen, es gibt halt diese Veranstaltungen, wo zum einen die Verhandlung von diesem Zero Draft, den Elisa gerade schon erwähnt hat, stattfindet. Aber parallel dazu gibt es noch so eine komplette Armada an zivilgesellschaftlichen Veranstaltungen, wo die Leute versuchen irgendwie ihre Schwerpunkte noch mal herauszustellen. Und das halt auch in Form von Panels. Die größeren NGOs kommen dann mit so sehr komprimierten Forderungskatalogen da an. Und das droppen die natürlich bei jeder Möglichkeit. Und je näher sie an die Verhandelten rankommen, desto besser, weil sie dann die Hoffnung haben, dass das dann doch irgendwie noch Berücksichtigung findet.
Nenn mal ein paar, damit man Beispiele hat. Was sind denn so die großen NGOs, die da mitmischen? Und was sind das so für politische Statements, die die da so ungefähr ablassen, dass man eine Idee bekommt?
Also, das muss man vielleicht dazusagen, hat mich persönlich auch überrascht. Es ist ja primär eine Frauenrechtsveranstaltung. Dementsprechend würde man natürlich als Netzpolitikmensch denkt man so, ja klar, irgendwie weiß ich nicht, so Exisnow, was fällt mir jetzt noch? So ein eDRI oder so die klassischen Digitalorganisationen sollten da ja eigentlich auftauchen, wenn das Thema Technologie irgendwie ist. Aber was tatsächlich der Fall ist, ist, dass da einfach Frauenrechtsorganisationen, also zum Beispiel wieder Deutsche Frauenrat, mir fällt gerade noch kein besseres Beispiel ein, vielleicht hat Elisa gleich noch ein Beispiel, da hinfahren, die eigentlich primär Frauenrechtsthemen auf ihren Agenten haben. Und ich glaube, das ist auch noch mal wichtig zu sagen, es gibt zwar dieses Überthema Technologie und Innovation, aber es gibt auch immer noch so ein, ich sag mal, so ein Bereich zum Thema Gleichstellung und Frauenrechte, der trotzdem immer noch damit drinsteckt. Also ich weiß nicht, Elisa, du hast es irgendwann mal gesagt, so irgendwie ist es so 60-40 von dem Verhältnis, was dann da tatsächlich diskutiert wird und dementsprechend fallen natürlich auch die Forderungen aus. Also, und das ist dann halt auch wieder von Land zu Land unterschiedlich. Das geht dann teilweise darum, einfach nur Frauen überhaupt Internet-Access zu geben, weil das in vielen Ländern einfach gar nicht der Fall ist. Das heißt, wir können eigentlich gar nicht über Technologie und Innovation reden, wenn der Großteil der Frauen einfach gar keinen Zugriff darauf hat. Es geht aber natürlich auch irgendwie so um Dinge wie Hassrede, ganz klassisches Thema irgendwie im Bereich Gendergerechtigkeit, wo dann überlegt wird, was können wir eigentlich machen?
Kannst du noch mehr Beispiele nennen, Elisa, wo du jetzt sagst, ah ja, NGOs, die auch international wahrscheinlich tätig sind, und was die so abgelassen haben an Forderungen, also nur mal um eine Idee zu bekommen, auf welchem Level da debattiert wird.
Also das erste Mal, dass ich so ein Pamphlet in die Hand gedrückt bekommen habe, das war direkt am Tag Null, am Samstag, als wir uns erstmal in der deutschen Delegation getroffen haben, und da hat uns eine Vertreterin von den Pfadfindern tatsächlich einen Einseiter gegeben. Die hatten sich also gut vorbereitet, das war auch schön gelayoutet, das war tatsächlich, da sieht man die richtigen Profis am Werke. Tatsächlich grundlegende Forderungen, wie Zugang, Ausbildungsgerechtigkeit. Und das ist was, was sich durchzieht. Elina hat es ja gerade schon gesagt, da sind vor allem Frauenrechtsorganisationen, spannenderweise eben auch viele Jugendorganisationen, weshalb die Demografie der Menschen, die dort sind, echt auch anders ist, als auf jeder anderen netzpolitischen Veranstaltung, auf der ich jemals war. Heißt aber auch, dass die Forderungen eben immer in einem sehr konkreten Kontext gesehen wurden und auch echt anders priorisiert werden, als wir das so vielleicht machen würden. Es gab einen so ein lustiges Phänomen, über das wir uns ab Tag zwei auch echt ein bisschen lustig gemacht haben, oder Elina? Nämlich, dass es immer um den Algorithmus ging. Also wir müssen irgendwie den Algorithmus in seine Schranken weisen, oder ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was an der Zeit so etwas war.
Und ich glaube, mein persönliches Highlight war dann, irgendwann sagte der Generalsekretär gutherrisch, also Algorithmen seien ja total diskriminierend, weil sie mit AI gebaut werden und das müssten wir ändern. Ich saß wirklich in der UNGA und er sagte diesen Satz und ich dachte mir so, okay, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll, was zu erklären. Also was da glaube ich, das sehr auffällig war, durch diese Frauenrechtsgeschichte, ist, dass da Begrifflichkeiten durcheinander geschmissen wurden, auf einem Level, das wir uns gar nicht vorstellen können. Also dagegen sind einige der deutschen Politikerinnen wirklich Technologie-Profis an einigen Stellen, muss man einfach so sagen.
Na gut, da ist sozusagen, da müssen wir vielleicht mal sagen, also wir haben alle Zugang zu Technik und wir befassen uns lange mit Technik und deswegen können wir irgendwie lachen über so einen Begriff wie Algorithmus, der mit Software offenbar gleichgesetzt wird, also den einen Algorithmus gäbe und so, aber lässig ist das ja Zeitungswissen. Und das ist ja, was du auch jeden Tag, wenn du die Zeitung aufklappst oder eben eine beliebige Webseite liest, also so wird der ja quasi derzeit übersetzt aus den eigentlich technologischen Bereichen. Das wundert mich jetzt nicht so doll, aber das ist ja natürlich jetzt weit weg von dem, was man sonst, wenn man sich mit Gesetzgebung oder so beschäftigt oder gerade in Brüssel, aber auch im Bundestag sieht. Aber ich will nochmal, bevor wir ein bisschen auf so Beispiele kommen, die ihr von verschiedenen Tagen bestimmt berichten könnt, nochmal kurz auf diesen Zero Draft zurück, damit wir zeigen können, wofür wir hin, also was ist denn das Endprodukt, was irgendwann dann mal rauskommt, also damit man auch nochmal ein Ende von dem Prozess versteht und dann vielleicht einordnen kann, was ihr zum Folgenden noch sagt.
Genau, das Endprodukt sind dann die sogenannten agreed conclusions, also die Beschlüsse, auf die sich das Plenum verständigt hat und die bestehen aus grob zwei Teilen. Der erste ist so ein ganz langer, kladerer Datsch, wo nochmal auf vorherige Beschlüsse Bezug genommen wird. Das ist auch so ein methodisches Vorgehen, das ich gelernt habe bei der UN, dass das dort eine sehr große Rolle spielt, immer wie so eine Argumentationskette aufzubauen. Wie wir schon 1984 und 1991 und 1997 festgestellt haben, ist das ein großes Problem und muss adressiert werden. Und daraus besteht wirklich fast die Hälfte dieser agreed conclusions, auch über die Hälfte des Zero Drafts. Und danach folgen dann sogenannte Empfehlungen. Wichtig ist noch hinzuzufügen, dass das natürlich nicht bindend ist, was da steht. Also da stehen Empfehlungen drin, da stehen Analysen drin, was ein wichtiges Arbeitsfeld wäre, dem man sich annähern möchte. Aber es ist also schon sehr inkonkret, ist vielleicht auch nicht verwunderlich bei so einem großen und auch echt sehr diversen Gremium.
Ja und vielleicht noch zwei Sachen, die ganz spannend sind. Also das Erste ist, wenn diese ganzen Empfehlungen, also diese Resolution dann am Ende fertig ist, die fassen dieses Thema dann für sechs Jahre nicht mehr an. Also es wird einmal da verhandelt und dann wird es in sechs Jahren noch mal reviewed und geguckt, was damit passiert ist. Das ist glaube ich das eine, was spannend ist und das andere, das hatten wir gerade noch gar nicht so gesagt. Elisa hat gerade ganz schön gesagt, es ist auch irgendwie so schwer, dass die sich einigen und sie machen diese Argumentationsketten. Was die auch machen und das ist glaube ich ein wesentlicher Unterschied auch dazu, wie in der EU häufig Gesetze verhandelt werden. Es geht da ganz, ganz viel um Wording und es gibt natürlich Parteien, die ein Interesse daran haben, ein besonders progressives Wording da reinzubringen und es gibt natürlich auch Parteien, die gerne möchten, dass sie zu einem konservativen Wording zurückgehen. Das heißt Teil dieser Verhandlung von dieser Resolution ist auch, dass beide Parteien versuchen, ihr Wording da reinzukriegen und dann auch beide Parteien zum Beispiel checken, die Leute, die das progressivere Wording da reinhaben wollen. Wenn Änderungsanträge sozusagen eingereicht werden, wurde schon mal ein progressiveres oder rückschrittigeres Wording in den letzten, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Jahren verwendet und wenn ja, dann versuchen die einfach bei dem progressivsten Wording zu bleiben. Weil wenn einmal diese Definition steht, dann kannst du da relativ gut drauf pochen, weil sie sich ja dann einmal darauf geeinigt haben, dass sie dieses Wording verwenden. Das heißt, da wird dann teilweise gar nicht über die Sache gesprochen, sondern wirklich irgendwie über so Mühsachen, wo wir alle sagen würden, ja, eigentlich aus meiner Sicht irrelevant, aber in dem Fall halt doch sehr relevant, was dann da tatsächlich steht.
Also für das Endergebnis dann, also für das Endprodukt, okay.
Wollen wir da mal ein paar Beispiele rangeben? Was so Wording sein kann, um das mal greifbar zu machen? Weil mir das zum Beispiel gar nicht klar war, dass da so ein fundamentaler Unterschied besteht zwischen, jetzt muss ich selber überlegen, Gleichberechtigung und Gleichstellung von Geschlechtern zum Beispiel. Dass das was fundamental Unterschiedliches ist. Und ich hab mich dauernd verhasst, und dann wurde ich immer korrigiert, als wäre ich so der letzte konservative Honk. Und das fühlte sich interessant an. Aber ich wollte ja eigentlich über Technologie sprechen, meine Güte. Insofern war das wirklich spannend. Das heißt aber auch, dass der Fokus bei den Verhandlungen wirklich auf dem Wording lag, wie das Elina gerade schon gesagt hat, und gar nicht so sehr über die technischen Inhalte. Also auch das nochmal eine echt spannende Erfahrung für uns, aber vielleicht auch manchmal so ein bisschen frustrierend war.
Was mir so auffällt, wenn ihr beide berichtet, ist der Zusammenhang, der mir kommt zu langen Urteilen. Also wenn man so höchstgerecht Urteile liest, und auch das Phänomen, dass es natürlich immer wieder einen Rückgriff gibt, der dass bestimmte Sachen nicht nochmal ausformuliert werden, sondern eben auf das Urteil von 2012 oder so verwiesen wird, da hat man ja was Ähnliches. Ist denn da, also zwei Fragen eigentlich, spielen da auch die Juristen eine große Rolle? Also ist das auch so ein bisschen juristifiziert, wie man das bei Gerichtsentscheidungen hat? Oder ist das hier weniger wichtig? Und zum anderen, warum bringen sich die Leute da ein, wenn es am Ende gar nicht bindend ist? Also wo sozusagen kommt die Energie her, sich dennoch in diese etwas witzigen Verhandlungen zu begeben, die Textarbeit auch mit einem physischen Zusammentreffen zu... Ja, das ist ja auch ein großer Aufwand. Also warum sind jetzt so ein bisschen zwei verschiedene Fragen? Oder sind da auch irgendwie Juristen, die dir dann festhammern? Oder wer sind die Menschen, die sich da einbringen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die beiden Mitarbeitenden, die für Deutschland verhandelt haben, Juristinnen sind. Ich glaube nicht.
Also das ist nicht so eine Juristensprache auch. Darum geht es nicht.
Ich glaube schon, dass es eine sehr juristische Sprache ist. Ich glaube aber, wenn man irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, gibt es so Verwaltungswissenschaften oder so. Oder so, ich glaube irgendwie eine Freundin von mir hat EU-Administration studiert. Das prädestiniert sich wahrscheinlich dafür, solche Sachen zu machen. Das heißt, das sind nicht unbedingt Juristinnen, das sind im Zweifelsfalle einfach Beamtinnen, die das da verhandeln, die auch gegebenenfalls natürlich in ihrem Administrationsbereich, sage ich mal, wahrscheinlich superkrasse Expertise haben. Aber jetzt für das Thema Technologie gar nicht. Das vielleicht um diese Frage zu beantworten. Und die Frage dazu, wieso bringt man sich da ein, wenn das nicht binden ist und so weiter und so fort. Ich glaube, man muss sich so ein bisschen der Symbolwirkung der UN bewusst werden. Also das ist mir auch bei der, ich war auch schon bei der OSZE. Und das ist mir schon aufgefallen, wenn man sagen kann, keine Ahnung, das und das UN-Gremium hat aber gesagt, dann ist das dann auf diesem diplomatischen Parkett schon sehr viel wert. Das heißt selbst oder obwohl das nicht bindend ist, ist es irgendwie dann dennoch wegweisend, wenn es um so diplomatische Policy-Diskussionen geht, wenn es auf UN-Ebene schon mal diskutiert und festgelegt wurde. Und ich glaube, das ist so das Ding. Und es kann dann halt auch anders herumgehen, dass es natürlich, wenn es eine total katastrophale Resolution ist, auch katastrophale Auswirkungen haben kann, weil es dann doch irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine Leitplanke ist, an der sich dann doch lang orientiert wird.
Aber eine Resolution ist es dann ja nicht, korrekt? Also im Vergleich dazu nochmal, um das auseinanderzuhalten.
Genau, ich glaube, das Stichwort ist wirklich Diplomatie. Also Constanze, du sagtest gerade, ist das eine juristische Sprache? Ich fand, das ist keine juristische Sprache, es ist eine diplomatische Sprache. Und das ist vielleicht nahe beieinander und auch alles sehr verklausuliert oder auch sehr symbolisch, aber es ist schon anders. Und das zu verstehen, dass das wirklich ein diplomatisches Parkett ist, auf dem ja schon auch Grundlagen gelegt werden für eine weitere Zusammenarbeit, vielleicht auch für Gräben, die sich auftun. Die Attraktivität kann ich schon verstehen, auch wenn ich sie jetzt nicht hundertprozentig teile, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber das war schon interessant zu sehen und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Leuten sehr, sehr, sehr viel Spaß macht. Und vielleicht noch als zweiten Punkt, warum Leute da gerne hinfahren. Also klar, ein Teil davon ist schlicht und ergreifend, es ist ihr Job, das sind Vertreterinnen von der ständigen Vertretung, den Staffs, also diese Art von Botschaften, die es da in New York gibt, die alle rundherum um dieses UN-Gebäude die krassesten Büros haben, mit den wildesten Aussichten.
Also die Stadt an sich ist natürlich auch irgendwie sexy, oder?
Natürlich, natürlich. Und ich glaube, es ist auch ein Wettrennen. Ich habe mehrfach gesagt, ich bin Teil der deutschen Delegation. Alle sagten, warst du schon in der Cafeteria, die Cafeteria hat die beste Aussicht. Und es stimmt. Also auch so spricht sich das rum, was eine interessante ständige Vertretung ist und wer nicht so richtig mithalten kann. Da gibt es ganz lustige Währungen. Und es gibt natürlich einmal dieses offizielle UN-Programm, das ist übrigens total schwer zu finden, weil das einfach nur so ein irgendwo verlinktes PDF ist. Das heißt auch gar nicht Programm. Das heißt Organization of Work. Also ich habe irgendwie drei Wochen gebraucht, bis ich das mal gefunden habe. Und dann gibt es die sogenannten Side Events. Das sind Veranstaltungen, die unter Teilnahme oder Mitorganisation der ständigen Vertretungen stattfinden. Das ist eine andere Liste von Veranstaltungen, die auch auf der UN-Seite, meine ich, findbar sind. Und dann gibt es noch mal die sogenannten Parallel Events. Und das sind dann die ganz armen Haschall aus der Zivilgesellschaft, die da in einem anderen Gebäude komplett ohne Sicherheitsvorkehrungen irgendwie ihre Sachen mit schlechter Internetanbindung machen dürfen. Und auch da wird diese zwei oder sogar drei Klassen Gesellschaft wieder relativ deutlich, wie schon die Programme ausgestaltet werden. Und ich muss sagen, inhaltlich die spannenden Sachen haben bei den Parallel Events stattgefunden. Also als zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation. Da waren die progressivsten, die tollsten, die inspirierendsten Sachen.
Dann würde ich mal noch gerne noch eine so richtig pragmatische Frage. Also auch um eine Idee zu bekommen, wenn man jetzt wahrscheinlich wie die allermeisten Menschen im Leben nieder hinfahren werden, um irgendwas zu verhandeln. Man kennt es ja aus Brüssel oder von den Höchstgerichten, die international sind. Da gibt es ja immer eine Form von Übersetzung. Die ist mehr oder minder schnell und die verzögert den Dialog ja enorm. Also wie ist es in New York? Wurde es übersetzt? Ist die Sprache Englisch? Oder wie ist diese ganze Übersetzung? Warum lacht ihr?
Also man muss dazu sagen, Elisa hat eine Übersetzerin kaputt gemacht, als wir in New York waren.
Und ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle formal dafür entschuldigen. Liebe Übersetzerinnen, liebe Übersetzer, es tut mir ausdrücklich leid.
Also vielleicht zum Background. Elisa durfte tatsächlich in einem offiziellen Event, in dem offiziellen, wie hieß das, Organization of Work Programm sprechen, das heißt, das ist jetzt auch sozusagen in der UN zu Akten gelegt, dass Elisa da gesprochen hat und im Rahmen dessen hat sie diese Übersetzerin kaputt gemacht.
Okay, war die ein Mensch oder war das ein Programm? Also das ist ein Mensch, also sind Übersetzer Menschen, ne?
Ein Mensch. Es sitzen Menschen, ich weiß es gar nicht, ich hab da gar nicht so drauf geachtet, muss ich sagen, in der GA, aber ich glaube, es ist so ähnlich wie im Sitzungssaal im EU-Parlament. Die sitzen da in ihren Böckschen und übersetzen das. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade wenn es sozusagen so diese Statements sind, das muss man vielleicht auch mal sich klar machen, das ist jetzt nicht so eine lebendige Diskussion zwischen den einzelnen Parteien, sondern da kommt wirklich jedes Land hin und es geht nicht um einen Diskurs, sondern es geht darum, sein Statement zu machen und seine Punkte klar zu machen. Das heißt, das liegt in der Regel vorher schon schriftlich vor, die wissen, was die da sagen. Das ist kein Zufall und kein Aufeinander eingehen oder sowas, gerade wenn das in diesen größeren Seelen stattfindet. Das heißt, die Übersetzung erfolgt basierend auf den Texten, die sie vorher abgeben.
Aber Elisa hat sich daran nicht so gehalten und frei gesprochen?
Oh nein, im Gegenteil. Ich dachte ja, ich war brav. Ich habe alle Deadlights eingehalten, Leute. Das war das allererste Mal in meinem Leben und habe sowohl meine schriftliche Statement als auch mein aufgeschriebenes mündliches Statement vorher eingereicht. Und dachte, gut, die Zeit tickt, ich habe nur acht Minuten, ich habe verdammt viel zu sagen, ich mache das zügig. Und danach wurde ich aber von der Gesprächsleiterin ermahnt, dass doch alle nachfolgenden Menschen noch ein bisschen langsamer zu sprechen hätten als ich. Aber hey, ich habe meinen Punkt gemacht.
Und deine Übersetzerin oder dein Übersetzer, die hat dann aufgegeben und die Waffen gestreckt, oder wie?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe mir selber zugehört. Übrigens, spannenderweise, es wird nur in sieben offizielle Sprachen übersetzt. Deutsch ist natürlich nicht dabei, es ist ja auch in Ordnung. Aber das heißt, ich hatte quasi gar keinen Anlass, das übersetzen zu lassen, weil ich die anderen Sprachen gar nicht so gut verstehe, in die das übersetzt wurde.
Aber hast du Deutsch oder Englisch gesprochen?
Englisch, Englisch natürlich.
Okay, das ist ja sogar schlechter eigentlich als zum Beispiel in Brüssel oder bei den europäischen Gerichten. Die haben durchaus mehr als sieben Sprachen.
Ja, also ich glaube, mir ist bei einer aufgefallen, also die spanische Übersetzung, muss ich sagen, war relativ langsam. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das auch aufgefallen ist bei dem Event bei dir, Elisa?
Ich verstehe Spanisch, ich hab der Übersetzung gar nicht zugehört, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ah, okay, also ich hab der Übersetzung auf Englisch zugehört. Ich verstehe auch ein bisschen Spanisch, aber nicht auf Diplomatisch. Und da war sie tatsächlich, und das fand ich erstaunlich, weil ich finde eigentlich so Spanisch und Französisch, und das ist auch häufig finde ich im EU-Parlament der Fall, da sind die eigentlich relativ gut. Also gerade wenn es irgendwie Englisch zu Französisch und andersrum ist. Und das war tatsächlich nicht der Fall. Und das fand ich schon erstaunlich, weil, wenn ich mir vorstelle, die kriegen die geschriebenen Statements vorher, dann haben die das ja im Zweifelsfall minimal vorbereitet. Also da war die Übersetzung dann doch ganz schön hinterher. Und so schnell, weiß ich nicht, hat die Spanierin schnell gesprochen?
Die hat relativ schnell gesprochen, aber das war für mich verständlich.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit zu lesen, wenn ich es recht verstanden habe. Also dadurch, dass da nichts Neues kommt oder keine Reaktion aufeinander, ist es ja nicht so furchtbar wichtig. Wer sitzt denn da und hört live zu, der nicht das Papier vor der Nase hat, wenn ich mal so einfach fragen darf?
Wollen wir jetzt noch mal das Zweiklassengesellschaftsfeld aufmachen?
Mir liegt daran, dass Leute einfach eine Idee kriegen, wie das so abläuft, weil ich glaube, dass das weithin unbekannt ist.
Also diese Zweiklassengesellschaft zieht sich tatsächlich durch das ganze Event. Also es ist zum Beispiel so, wir kamen da an und Elisa sagt dann, ja, ich bekomme meinen UN-Hausausweis dann heute Abend in der Botschaft beim Essen und ich stand tatsächlich fast drei Stunden in der Schlange vor der UN-Administration, um meinen Ausweis abzuholen und das war tatsächlich, jeden Tag war die Schlange so lang, dass sie fast einmal bis um den Block ging. Fast den ganzen 14 Tage durch, wo man sich dann immer fragt, okay, das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass sie das organisieren, aber gut. So, da fing das schon an.
Das ist eine absichtliche Missorganisation, also ist das einfach nicht besonders sexy für die, dass die Gesellschaft da reinkommt, geben sie sich keine Mühe, haben die Arbeitsplätze, Mangel oder was ist das Problem?
Ich kann dir nicht sagen, woran das liegt, aber es geht dann halt weiter. Das ist total spannend, nämlich wenn man einen Delegationsausweis hat, muss man nicht durch die Sicherheitskontrolle. Wenn man einen anderen, anders gearteten Zivilgesellschaftsausweis hat, muss man immer durch diese Flughafensicherheitspiepkontrolle mit Taschescannen und allem drum und dran. So, das ist so der Anfang, das zieht sich so durch. Und das nächste ist dann, als Elisa ihren Vortrag gehalten hat, ist das so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr so diese Bilder von den UN-Seelen im Koffer, wahrscheinlich von der General Assembly, das ist aber ein anderer Raum gewesen. Und da gibt es sozusagen immer so ein Groundfloor, wo dann auch überall so die Schildchen dran sind von den einzelnen Länderdelegationen. Und der ist auch tatsächlich nur für die Vertreterinnen der Länder reserviert. Und dann gibt es eine Tribüne. Und das ist dann sozusagen für die Zivilgesellschaft. Und man kommt auch nicht darunter. Also ich wollte irgendwie Elisa noch irgendwas sagen oder irgendwas geben. Die haben mich, also die haben uns erstmal erst Punkt. Zu der Uhrzeit, wo das angefangen hat, reingelassen die Zivilgesellschaft. Und wir durften halt auch nicht darunter, um irgendwie mit irgendjemandem zu sprechen.
Du hast es aber versucht, ne?
Ich hab's versucht. Ich hab so getan, als wenn ich irgendwie Elisas Assistentin wäre. Aber es hat leider nicht geklappt.
Na gut, aber das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so überraschend, oder? Also es ist eine riesige Organisation, die machen sich ihre Regeln. Wer weiß, wie die sich mal gebildet haben. Wahrscheinlich gibt es auch noch eine vierte Klasse, das sind wahrscheinlich Presse oder so, die werden noch schlechter behandelt, oder? Keine Ahnung. Also mich überrascht jetzt nicht, dass die unterschiedlich behandelt werden. Mich eher überrascht das jetzt so ein bisschen die D's-Organisation. Also dass sie das nicht mal irgendwie effizient hinbekommen, finde ich schon für so eine alte Organisation ein bisschen bedauerlich.
Wollen wir noch unsere Lieblingsgeschichte erzählen? Vom Frauentag? Ok, also, 8. März war Frauentag, der sollte natürlich auch angemessen in der General Assembly gefeiert werden, so mit Rahmenprogrammen und Musik und lala, was man halt so macht in der UN. Und im Vorfeld hatten wir schon so eine Mail gekriegt, wo dann war so, ja, klickt euch bitte vorher ein Ticket, weil der Andrang für diese Veranstaltung ist so groß.
Über Eventbrite wohlgemerkt. Das ist Eventbrite.
Ja gut, aber dieses Thema Eventbrite, Google Forms und alles Mögliche, das hat sich sowieso durch dieses ganze Event gezogen. Aber hat man sich so ein Eventbrite-Ticket geklickt? Und ich glaube, zwei Tage bevor wir angereist sind, kam dann die Mail. Ja, die hätten das Event überbucht. Und deswegen ist so erster und zweiter Tag, fürs Come, fürs Surf, kann man sich die Tickets in der Lobby abholen. Und am ersten Tag, du kannst es dir nicht vorstellen, du kommst in diese Lobby und wirklich als wenn, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie eine Limited Edition, weiß ich nicht, was gibt, also so wie wenn es Kongress-Shirts gibt, stehen die Leute Schlange, um so ein Ticket zu bekommen. Ich habe dann halt so gesagt, boah, nee, gar keine Lust, ich gebe mir das nicht.
Wart ihr da gleich behandelt oder wart ihr da wieder zwei Klassen?
Nee, Elisa hat ihr Ticket natürlich wieder über die ständige Vertretung bekommen.
Aber du wolltest wieder drei Stunden stehen müssen.
Naja, das geht noch weiter. Ich hätte dann wieder drei Stunden stehen müssen. Hab ich halt nicht gemacht und am ersten Tag waren natürlich alle Tickets weg. Ich war am Ende auch nicht böse drum, weil du kommst in diese General Assembly, also als zivilgesellschaftliche Vertreterin, nur über den Haupteingang und dann über die Fahrstühle. Das heißt, du kannst dir auch nicht vorstellen, wie die Schlange vor dem Fahrstuhl war, damit die Leute dann an dem Tag selber in diese General Assembly kamen. Das heißt, da war auch ein Hauen und Stechen. Und ich glaube, Elisa kann ja mal erzählen, wie es auf der anderen Seite aussah, auf dem First Class Eingang.
Okay, nämlich?
Genau, also bei uns spielte sich das Ganze ein bisschen anders, aber eigentlich nicht weniger verkorkst ab. Wir hatten auch erst das Okay bekommen. Also erst, wir müssen uns über Eventbrite anmelden. Das hab ich dann irgendwie gemacht. Dann wurde ich aber auch noch über Eventbrite angemeldet und hab nur noch mal so einen zweiten Link bekommen von irgendeiner, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie Laura irgendwas oder so, keine Ahnung, die das für mich da angelegt hatte. Na gut, tolles Service, vielen Dank. Und dann hieß es aber, nee, es ist auch für uns überbucht und das wäre ohnehin alles ganz unklar. Und dann haben wir aber so Papierschildchen bekommen, so für deine grüne Kärntchen, wo quasi steht hier so das goldene Ticket, um doch noch an dieser Veranstaltung teilzunehmen. Aber, zwei Klassengesellschaft, wir müssen einen anderen Eingang zur General Assembly nehmen, zu diesem großen Raum. Wir hatten einen Fahrstuhl, aber da war auch eine Schlange, weshalb uns dann so ein netter Sicherheitsmann noch sagte, so, geht mal da hin und dann irgendwie, also schickte uns so durch diesen Raum, durch dieses Gebäude hindurch und dann haben wir einen anderen Fahrstuhl gefunden und waren dann tatsächlich dann doch relativ flott oben. Und dann standen da, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, irgendwie, ich weiß nicht was, 300 Delegierte, die unbedingt diese neue Limited Edition Sneaker sich irgendwie abholen wollten und haben sich angestellt in einem riesigen Polk vor zwei völlig hilflosen Sicherheitsmenschen, die mir wirklich Leid tun, weil die irgendwie uns mit all diesem wir haben ein Recht darauf, bei diesem Frauentag dabei zu sein, mit diesem Spirit, die uns da irgendwie einfangen mussten. Und die haben dann auch erst angesagt, hier, wir sollten zwei Reihen bilden, eine, die so nach links rum abbiegt, eine, die nach rechts rum abbiegt, weil das auch einen totalen Engpass war, dieser Einlass. Und dann kam aber Denise Fure aus dem Aufzug und kam dazu und stellte sich natürlich in der Mitte an. Dann gab es da ein Gerangel und es wurde passiv-aggressiv darauf hingewiesen, dass wir hier ja zwei Reihen bilden würden und dann haben die Leute das nicht verstanden, dass sie sich daran stellen sollten und dann wurde es noch ein bisschen ruppiger. Also es war ganz, ganz großes Kino. Und als dann irgendwie nur Anstalten waren, dass das Ding jetzt geöffnet wird, da wurden diese Sicherheitsmenschen einfach völlig platt gemacht und wurden echt über einen Haufen gerannt. Und der Saal fühlt es sich rapial. Oder waren Männer? Ja, da waren Männer oder kam es zu meiner persönlichen Lieblingsszene in dieser ganzen Veranstaltung. Wollen wir direkt dazu übergehen, zu dieser schönen Frauentagsveranstaltung?
Ja, das ist Diplomatie, wollte ich nur kurz noch sagen.
Das ist auch Diplomatie, das stimmt. Also es ging los mit der Ansage, es waren schöne Reden, es waren auch wirklich schöne Momente da drin. Es ging aber los mit der Aufforderung, dass wir zu einer Frau, die neben uns oder vor uns oder hinter uns sitzt, die wir noch nicht können, die wir noch nicht kennen, dass wir uns zu der umdrehen sollen und sie angucken sollen und ihr sagen, you are fabulous. Du bist fabelhaft. Ja, haben wir auch gemacht. Wir guckten uns an und sagten, you are fabulous und wir sahen uns ein ein bisschen peinlich, aber gut. Und der nächste Satz war, dass die Männer im Raum, die wenigen gebeten wurden, aufzustehen und dann sollten alle Frauen ihnen applaudieren, weil sie ja so tolle Allies sind.
Und weil wir das ja auch ohne die auf gar keinen Fall schaffen würden, irgendwas hinzubekommen.
Das war in der Tat awkward, es wurde noch awkwarder, als der eine Mann, der vor mir stand, dann sein Handy rauszog und den ganzen, also filmte, wie der ganze Raum ihm quasi Beifall klatschte. Es war eine sehr aufgeladene Situation, sagen wir es so.
Also ich würde mal vorschlagen, wir lassen diese Feierlichkeiten um den Frauentag jetzt mal beiseite und kommen mal zu sozusagen dem Kern von dem, was ihr bisher da inhaltlich verhandelt habt. Einfach um mal, ey, it is the UN, wir haben jetzt eine Idee, wie die organisiert ist, wir kennen die Klassengesellschaft, wir wissen den Zweck, aber wir kennen noch nicht den Inhalt. Also mal zu schauen, was wird da vermutlich bei rumkommen und wo ist jetzt der Stand der Diskussion und jetzt nennst du doch mal die vermutlichen Empfehlungen, die dabei rumkommen. Wird alles besser?
Nein. Die ganz klare Antwort darauf finde ich, muss lauten nein. Und das hat sich auch bei unterschiedlichen Gesprächen mit unterschiedlichen, ja, progressiven Delegationen gezeigt, dass sie gesagt haben, ganz ehrlich, das Technische ist gerade für uns gar nicht so sehr relevant. Wir sehen gerade einen weltweiten konservativen Backlash und ich meine, das glaube ich, können wir auch alle nachvollziehen, dass das so ist. Unser Fokus liegt darauf, die diese Sprache, die sich etabliert hat, wie Elina schon vorhin sagte, die zu verteidigen, die vielleicht noch so ein bisschen zuzuspitzen. Ich weiß, es war auch so eine konzertierte Aktion zu sagen, wir wollen endlich aufhören, nur von Männern und Frauen zu reden, was ja auch durchaus Sinn ergibt. Und stattdessen stärker zu sagen, wir müssen intersektional auf Diskriminierung gucken, auf Benachteiligung gucken und es wurde versucht, dieses Wort intersektional in den Agreed Conclusions zu verankern und soweit ich weiß, ist das nicht geglückt. Also die Endfassung ist noch nicht veröffentlicht.
Die ist noch nicht veröffentlicht, ich hab das schon erwähnt, wird sich ja noch hinziehen, aber sagt man trotzdem, also ihr habt ja jetzt einen gewissen Stand oder Ende der Veranstaltung oder bis zum Ende besucht, wo ist denn der Stand jetzt? Und vielleicht noch, wenn ihr könnt, die Timeline.
Naja, vielleicht sollte man an der Stelle nochmal sagen, wir haben das Ding halt nicht mit verhandelt. Also wir waren zwar die ganze Zeit da, aber wir haben von dem, was da verhandelt wurde, außer die Briefings, die wir von der ständigen Vertretung bekommen haben, nichts mitbekommen. Wir haben dann gelernt, also wir sind da so ein bisschen blauäugig, glaube ich auch, würde ich sagen, oder das heißt blauäugig, ja, so ein bisschen blauäugig hingegangen, haben gesagt, naja, die werden uns ja schon erklären, was wir jetzt da noch leisten können. Und wir haben auch gelernt, dass teilweise, dass die Leute aus der offiziellen Delegation auch das Recht haben, in diesen Verhandlungsräumen mitzusitzen, wenn sie das denn wollen. Das hat uns aber zu spät erreicht, diese Information, würde ich mal sagen. Deswegen können wir da sozusagen, Widerstand nach den zwei Wochen waren, gar nicht so genau was sagen. Und ich glaube, es wird jetzt noch ein bisschen dauern. Aber ich kann, ich habe die genaue Timeline, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, nicht parat. Ich weiß nicht, Elisa, ob du da besser auf dem Sprung bist. Weil ich glaube, es sind noch so zwei Monate und dann sollte das eigentlich raus sein, ne?
Also soweit ich das weiß, geht es jetzt wirklich nur noch darum, die Nummerierung zu prüfen und so weiter. Das geht gerade noch mal durch einen redaktionellen Prozess, der aber kein inhaltlicher mehr ist. Und dann wird es veröffentlicht. Das kann sich eigentlich nicht mal lange hinziehen.
Hm, naja, aber dann, also ich sehe sie jetzt schon, weil ihr sie schon niedergeschrieben habt, aber was ist das, worauf sich die UN dann einigen werden in dem nicht bindenden Beschluss? Ihr nennt es mal, also sag es doch mal.
Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass alle Frauen und Mädchen weltweit Zugang zum Internet haben. Also es sind tatsächlich solche Aussagen. Wir müssen den Anteil von Frauen...
Das ist natürlich für viele Millionen Menschen überhaupt nicht Realität. Insofern ist es dir erstmal auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Der klassische Fall add women and stir. Also wir brauchen mehr Frauen in Computer Science, in Start-ups. Es wird dann auch schon sehr schnell sehr waberig. Also ich glaube, das Berufsbild war auch so ein bisschen unklar da. Aber wir müssen irgendwie mehr Frauen in Position bringen, wo die...
Mathematik, Informatik, Naturwissenschaft, Technik. Richtig?
Aber eben auch in den Wirtschaftsbereich. Also es geht nicht um die akademische Ausbildung. Ich glaube, das ist relativ neoliberal gefasst. Das heißt, es wird auch immer so argumentiert, da entgeht uns ja auch ein potenzielles Wirtschaftswachstum, wenn die Frauen dann nicht programmierend den Gründern zur Seite stehen.
Ja und ich glaube, das ist auch irgendwie... Das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen dieser Irrglaube. Und das klang da auch an sehr vielen Stellen durch, dass sozusagen Innovation das Heilmittel ist. Und wenn Frauen dann partizipieren an dieser Innovation, dann wird das ja auch irgendwie eine gerechtere Innovation sein, die wir da bekommen. Das ist so ein bisschen glaube ich so das, was sich da so durchgezogen hat. Und Elisa hat gerade noch schon mal gesagt, dass wir so einen konservativen Backlash da sehen. Und den sehen wir tatsächlich auch in der Art wie über Technologie und wie über Regulierung von Technologie gesprochen wird. Also das zeichnet sich da auch ganz klar ab, dass es halt wirklich so dieses krass protektionistische Technologie sorgt dafür, dass Frauen Gewalt ausgesetzt sind. Und deswegen ist Technologie böse. Und deswegen müssen wir keine Ahnung super krasse Maße anlegen, was so Scannen von Content angeht und automatisiertes Offline-Schalten und solche Geschichten. Also das zieht sich da glaube ich so durch. Und dieser Trend, den wir irgendwie in der EU sehen, der ist da irgendwie nochmal ein zehnfaches größer und höher und problematischer durch diese konservativen Sichtweisen, die sich da auch so eingenistet haben.
Wir haben jetzt immer so ein bisschen westliche Sicht auf die Welt. Aber jeder weiß, in der UN sind natürlich auch eine Menge Staaten, die keine oder sagen wir mal nicht besonders gute demokratische Standards haben. Wir haben also Diktaturen wie aus den Buche, die sind ja auch Teil der UN. Also wie ist es denn, wie kann da irgendwie eine Brücke überwunden werden zwischen relativ demokratischen Ländern, die gewisse Standards erfüllen, auch eine gewisse, ich nenne jetzt mal Diskussionsbreite haben in ihren Gesellschaften und irgendwie so schlimmen Diktaturen, wo das nicht der Fall ist. Wie wird das überbrückt? Wird das überhaupt überbrückt?
Es ist ein diplomatisches Parkett, also gestritten wird da nicht. Elina hat gerade schon erzählt, wie so eine Sitzung abläuft, dass da alle irgendwie ihr Sprüchlein aufsagen, aber es kommt kein Gespräch zustande. Das ist dann, wenn es ums konkrete Wording geht, nochmal was anderes, da wird dann schon auch debattiert, aber da geht es wirklich um Begriffe, es geht nicht um Konzepte, es geht nicht um politische Programme, das ist mein Eindruck. Und weil du gerade spannenderweise sagtest, wir haben unseren westlichen Blick, ich habe aus der deutschen Delegation die Einschätzung gehört, dass tatsächlich die mit Abstand progressivsten Punkte von den Pacific Islander Staaten eingebracht wurden. Also, dass die wirklich so vorausgerannt sind und auch wirklich krasse Forderungen aufgestellt sind, was natürlich auch die Verhandlungen schon mal verschiebt, das ist auch ganz spannend. Und gleichzeitig haben wir aber, es geht um Frauenrechte, wir haben sehr viel Rede über das nordische Modell, das von den skandinavischen Staaten als, wie so eine Monstranz vor sich hergetragen wird. Und sie sagen sogar selbst, wir kommen aus Skandinavien, deswegen müssen wir in jeder Diskussion das nordische Modell ansprechen. Wo es also auf einmal ganz stark darum geht, Trafficking, also Menschenhandel und Sexarbeit zusammenzuwerfen und irgendwie in einen so Topf und dann alles zu kriminalisieren auf die gleiche Art und Weise, ist für mich jetzt auch nicht der progressivste Ansatz. Das heißt, da sind sehr, sehr viele Schichten und sehr viele Gemengelagen, spannenderweise, die da aufeinandertreffen.
Nun muss ich euch die Frage stellen, ich hoffe, dass ein paar Hörer und Hörerinnen, die auch hätten, würdet ihr es nochmal machen? Also lohnt sich das aus eurer Sicht? Ich frage jetzt äquizit eure beiden Perspektiven. Ich glaube, diese klassische zivilgesellschaftliche Perspektive und die als Teilnehmer einer Delegation, auch privilegiert in gewisser Weise, ist vielleicht eine andere.
Ich würde es natürlich nur nochmal machen, wenn Elisa auch mitkommt. Also ich würde es auf jeden Fall nochmal tun. Ich habe da unheimlich viel gelernt darüber, wie die Sachen so liegen in der UN und was vielleicht auch nötig ist an Vorbereitungen, auch in Kooperation mit der deutschen Bundesregierung zum Beispiel, um sozusagen eine Basis zu legen, wo man wirklich sinnvoll partizipieren kann und auch seine Expertise, weil das fand ich irgendwie so schade daran, dass da wirklich dann doch viel Expertise da war, die aber einfach keinen Einfluss genommen hat, weil wir nicht wie die Fahrtfinderinnen mit diesem supernice Talking Point-Boklett da angekommen sind, sondern da aufgeschlagen sind und gesagt haben, hier sind wir und jetzt hört uns mal zu. Und das funktioniert halt leider nicht. Und ich glaube, das wäre so das Learning. Ich würde dann halt mit meinem Booklet da auftauchen und würde vorher auch mal die deutsche Bundesregierung oder das BMFSJ anzählen und sagen so, hey, wer sind denn die Verantwortlichen bei euch? Wie ist denn der Diskussionsstand? Was sind irgendwie Fragen, die sich da auftun? Und hier ist übrigens mein Input, und das am besten irgendwie schon vier Monate vorher. Das muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen. Es war sehr kurzfristig, dass wir dahin gefahren sind. Also wir haben das, ich glaube, es sind nur so zwei Monate vorher, oder bei mir waren es, glaube ich, zwei Monate vorher, dass wir sicher wussten, dass wir dahin fahren. Und das ist natürlich für zivilgesellschaftliche Vertreterinnen, die irgendwie noch andere Grabenkämpfe zu führen haben, nicht so viel Zeit, um sich in seiner Freizeit auf so was Großes vorzubereiten. Und ich glaube, das wäre so der Grund, warum ich noch mal hinfahren würde, auf jeden Fall, um halt dann besser vorbereiteter und strategisch schlauer mich in diesen Prozess einzubringen.
Ja, aber lass uns das doch mal konkreter machen, weil wir haben ja eigentlich schon was im Petto, oder?
Du musst erst mal die Frage beantworten, Elisa. Vorher darfst du nicht weitermachen.
Also genau, dann beantworte ich sie genau damit. Wir sind natürlich angefixt und strukturell unzufriedener zurückgekommen und sehen natürlich ganz großen Handlungsbedarf. Und das Spannende ist, dass auf der CSW, auf dieser Konferenz, sehr oft ein UN-Vorhaben referenziert wurde, das jetzt nicht von dieser Frauenrechtskommission betrieben wird oder durchgeführt wird. Und das ist der Global Digital Compact. Das ist gerade ein großes, wie sagt man, Multi-Stakeholder-Format, das 2024 vorgestellt werden soll. Und naja, wie der Name schon sagt, global digital Themen zusammenbinden soll. Und da fühlten wir uns natürlich direkt angesprochen. Da gibt es gerade von der UN ein Konsultationsverfahren. Es ist mir völlig schleierhaft, was mit diesen Konsultationsantworten, mit den Beiträgen, die da geleistet werden, passiert. Aber, um mal das Ganze zurückzuführen auf Berlin, die Vorstellung erfolgt im Rahmen des Summits of the Future. Das ist eine Konferenz, die 2001 beschlossen wurde, soweit ich weiß. Und die sich vor allem um strukturelle Nachhaltigkeitsfragen und die Bewältigung von vernetzten Krisen oder verknüpften Krisen damit befassen soll. Und die wird von Deutschland und Namibia organisiert und ausgerichtet in New York bei der UN. Das heißt, da sehen wir dann doch auch die Bundesregierung eigentlich ganz gut in der Pflicht, sich noch mal zu öffnen und auch dafür zu sorgen, dass Zivilgesellschaft strukturell beteiligt wird, über und rein, als hier mal die drei Fragen ausfüllen hinaus.
Und vielleicht noch mal zwei Sachen, die zu dem Global Digital Compact oder drei ganz wichtig sind. Der ist auch wieder nicht bindend. Also es ist wieder sozusagen eine Leitplanke, die sie da einziehen, an die man sich halten kann, muss man aber nicht. Und ich glaube, das zweite, was ganz wichtig ist zu wissen, ist, wir sehen ja gerade, also wir sehen schon seit Jahren, so Entwicklungen in, ich sag mal, Technologieregulierung, die teilweise gut sind, aber teilweise auch hoch problematisch. Gerade was so, wenn es daran geht, so wirklich so Internetinfrastruktur anzugreifen, da sehen wir relativ viele problematische Gesetzgebungen. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, ja toll, wenn die UN das macht, dann können die ja mal dafür sorgen, zu sagen, dass das eine blöde Idee ist, was hier gerade alles läuft und irgendwie mal ein bisschen Feuer wieder irgendwie so in Internet-Standardisierung zu bringen. Das wäre so das Optimum. Das wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht passieren. Und mit diesem Global Digital Compact laufen wir im Prinzip Gefahr, dass dieses aktuelle Multistakeholder-Modell, das wir haben für Internet-Standardisierung, gefährdet wird. Und dass es sein kann, dass die UN versuchen wird, das sozusagen zu einem offiziellen Body von sich zu machen. Und sozusagen dieser interessanten UN-Bürokratie, die wir da gesehen haben, zu unterstellen, was natürlich eine totale Vollkatastrophe wäre. Das heißt, diesen Global Digital Compact sollte man wirklich gut im Auge behalten. Und das ist der Grund, warum Elisa und ich da dran mitarbeiten werden. Und vielleicht auch ab und an mal darüber berichten werden, was da jetzt eigentlich gerade so passiert. Und mal schauen, ob die Bundesregierung vielleicht auch nochmal schaut, dass sie die zivilgesellschaftlichen Expertinnen und Experten da entsprechend mit einbindet. Weil bisher, wir haben mal so rumgefragt bei anderen netzpolitischen Organisationen, haben noch nicht so viele davon gehört. Und es wurden auch irgendwie nicht mal nach Input oder Ähnlichem gefragt.
Aber ich nehme mal folgendes mit. Trotzdem, ihr einige Witzigkeiten beobachtet habt, ihr wollt auf jeden Fall weiterhin dicke Bretter bohren. Und ich würde erstmal sagen, das passt gut zu unserem Podcastprojekt. Denn das ist ja unser Oberthema. Wie entstehen so eine Policies? Wie werden Meinungen gemacht? Wie bildet sich auch eine Form von Konsens? Und am Ende werden ja doch irgendwie Gesetze draus, wenn man da die nationale Ebene dazunimmt. Und das soll unser Projekt bei diesem Podcast sein. Und unsere erste Runde, die ihr eben gehört habt, die bezog sich auf die Vereinten Nationen. Und ich glaube, wer jetzt keinen Einblick hat, der kann in die Kommentare bei uns natürlich auch Fragen stellen, die wir gerne aufgreifen. Oder aber auch Ideen, die für nächste Podcastprojekte, wo auch dicke Bretter zu bohren sind im Bereich von Policy, vielleicht ein Vorschlag für uns wären. Da würden wir uns bedanken. Und außerdem wollen wir uns bedanken bei EdGast. Der hat uns die Musik gemacht, die wir jetzt noch mal hören. Und wir sagen Tschüss.